merci anne claire legendre d'être avec
nous vous êtes diplomate et porte parole
du ministère de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères tout d'abord que fait
l'ambassade de france à kiev
actuellement bonjour merci de m'avoir en
plateau de l'ambassade de france à kiev
est toujours en place à kiev elle est en
contact évidemment quotidiennement avec
nos communautés françaises qui sont
toujours présentes en ukraine et elle
est en contact avec les autorités
ukrainiennes pour continuer à faire tout
le travail que nous faisons de soutien
et de solidarité à l'ukraine s'il ya des
millions de réfugiés est ce que la
france devra prendre sa part le
président de la république s'est exprimé
le ministre l'a redit nous avons décidé
ça a été une discussion aussi en conseil
européen d'hier et en conseil affaires
étrangères hier évidemment d'exprimer
notre solidarité vis-à-vis des réfugiés
et craignant cela se fera dans le cadre
coordonné dans l'union européenne le
ministre gérald darmanin se rendra
demain au conseil affaires intérieures
pour discuter des dispositifs à mettre
en oeuvre pour accueillir les déplacés
et les réfugiés d'ukrainiens est ce que
la france est prête à exfiltrer même si
on le voit il fait des communiqués via
des vidéos il a l'air bien il est pour
l'instant toujours à kiev le président
hélène ce qui met ce qu'elle est prête
elle à l'exfiltrer ou en tout cas à
garantir la vie sauve du président
ukrainien volodimir zelensky je ne crois
pas que ce soit là qui sont aujourd'hui
le président zelensky se montre à
l'oeuvre sur le terrain et je crois
qu'il fait preuve d'une détermination et
d'un courage que nous saluons tous et
qui inspire aujourd'hui le peuple
ukrainien et le monde entier pour avoir
une diplomatie efficace
il ya deux conditions 1 s'est développé
le rapport de force on a vu avec les
sanctions américaines et européennes et
qui vont peut-être gravir un échelon et
il va faire une proposition de sortie de
crise acceptable par l'ensemble des
parties est ce qu'il y a actuellement
une proposition
la proposition elle être faite par le
président de la république vous savez
qu'ils avaient avant l'invasion russe se
poser les conditions avec la totalité de
nos alliés européens et transatlantiques
des conditions d'une sortie de crise
d'une désescalade que nous avons pu
constater c'est que vladimir poutine à
rejeter à la fois c'est ouverture au
dialogue ouverture au dialogue qui a été
aussi celle du président zielinski et la
totalité de ses engagements y compris au
regard des accords de minsk donc
aujourd'hui notre message c'est celui de
la fermeté de la détermination et la
solidarité vis-à-vis d'eux crenn le
président de la république a eu le
président poutine à la demande du
président de leninsky et il l'a appelé à
la cessation des combats et c'est le
message qui a été passé hier par l'union
européenne par le conseil de sécurité où
vous savez que la russie hier s'est
trouvée complètement isolé et donc il
n'y a pas d'autre proposition si pour
l'instant c'est juste le retrait des
troupes russes aujourd'hui c'est la
cessation des combats et évidemment le
retrait des troupes russes c'est ce qu'a
demandé aussi le secrétaire général des
nations-unies ce qu'il faut c'est
aujourd'hui c'est les bombardements sur
des populations civiles ce sont les
ukrainiens aujourd'hui qui souffrent
sans aucune provocation de leur part il
faut quand même le rappeler une violence
et une invasion sur la totalité de leur
territoire contrairement à ce
qu'indiquent les autorités russes si
jamais le chemin de la négociation et de
la diplomatie reprend est ce qu'il
faudrait pas proposé un accord global de
sécurité pour l'ensemble des pays
européens dont la russie alors c'est ce
que nous avions proposé non pas un
accord global mais en tout cas définir
un ordre de sécurité des garanties de
sécurité pour l'europe qui permettrait
de traiter toute une série de questions
qui se traite dans des enceintes
différentes et c'est pour ça que nous
avions ouvert avec la russie des canaux
de discussion différentes donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a constaté c'est à
la fois le refus la russie de rentrer
dans une discussion sur la totalité de
ses canaux évidemment aujourd'hui une
invasion majeur au coeur de l'europe qui
change complètement la situation
géopolitique n'est pour vous là
actuellement il ya plus rien à négocier
où vous dites qu'il ya quand même un
encore matière à négocier si c'est
possible avec le dirigeant russe le
suédois évidemment aboutir à un arrêt
des violences et ensuite un retour à
l'ordre international un retour à la
reconnaissance pleine et entière de la
souveraineté de l'ukraine il est évident
que si le président poutine souhaitait
rentrer dans cette logique nous
souhaiterions pouvoir rouvrir des
discussions mais cela ne semble pas le
cas à l'heure actuelle même s'il a
proposé des pourparlers à minsk au
niveau ministériel voit bien que dans
les conditions de l'actuelle salle
propositions sont assez peu sérieuse et
consistante qu'en est il de la
résistance possible d'après vos
informations de l'armée ukrainienne et
de l'ensemble des hommes d'ukrainiens
mobilisés vous avez entendu les
déclarations du président heinz qui donc
je ne vais pas me faire le porte parole
de de l'ukraine du peuple ukrainien mais
ce que l'on constate c'est une
résistance sur le terrain et une volonté
de la part des ukrainiens de tenir face
à cette invasion russe et vous pensez
qu'une par exemple une guerre de
guérilla est envisageable selon vos
informations je ne vais pas faire de la
politique fiction le président de la
république s'est exprimé ce matin pour
dire qu'il pensait que la guerre serait
longue qu'il fallait se préparer à faire
face à une guerre qui durerait et donc
nous allons nous mettre en position nous
diplomatie française de tenir face face
à cette a7 à cette perspective à la fois
en développant comme on l'a dit un
paquet de sanctions majeure contre la
russie mais aussi en nous mettant en
posture de pouvoir peut-être en adopter
davantage et vous savez que la
discussion se poursuit en europe mais
aussi de soutenir nos alliés du flan
reste puisque évidemment l'otan s'est
mobilisée il ya eu hier là aussi un
sommet de l'otan sans précédent avec des
mesures sans précédent qui ont été
prises et enfin pour les économies aussi
faire en sorte que nos économies soient
protégés et nos entreprises ne payent
pas nos concitoyens ne paye pas le prix
de cette situation est ce que la france
va envoyer des armes à l'ukraine alors
ce n'est pas à moi de répondre je suis
la porte parole du ministère de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères
par ailleurs pour les sanctions le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
bruno le maire a dit qu'il était
favorable pour être pour exclure pour
l'exclusion la rue de la russie de swift
le système de transactions financières
internationales pourquoi l'allemagne s'y
opposent puisque visiblement l'italie
s'y opposait mais c'est en train
d'évoluer en fonction des dernières
déclarations de mario draghi alors la
main en italien la france en effet est
tout à fait favorable à ce que nous
puissions aller dans cette discussion la
discussion se poursuit au niveau de
l'union européenne le paquet qu'on a
adopté hier est un paquet absolument
spectaculaire sans précédent de
sanctions massives qui vont vraiment
asphyxier l'économie russe en mettant à
bas puisque 70% de son système bancaire
est directement visé par les sanctions
que nous avons imposé il ya notre
objectif c'était d'aller vite et pour
aller vite nous avons travaillé très
activement dès mardi jean yves le drian
avait réuni tous ses homologues ici à
paris pour adopter un premier paquet de
sanctions nous ne sommes réunis à à
bruxelles hier pour adopter ce paquet de
sanctions donc la discussion elle se
poursuit aujourd'hui sur sur d'autres
évolutions et d'autres mesures qui
pourraient venir encore renforcée et
swift en fait partie bien évidemment
vous parler d' asphyxie mais certains
experts disent que des experts disent
que ce n'est pas suffisant et qu'il
faudrait un boycott de toutes les
exportations russes qu'en pensez vous je
crois que nous n'avons pas encore
mesurer l'effet que cela va avoir sur
l'économie russe l'économie russe vous
savez c'est déjà un pipe équivalent à
celui de l'espagne ce n'est pas une
économie extrêmement forte donc bien sûr
ils ont des réserves en devises c'est
souvent l'argument que nous imposent les
experts mais aujourd'hui quand on
regarde le panorama des actions qui ont
été prises c'est à la fois tout le
secteur financer des secteurs
stratégiques le secteur énergétique le
secteur des raffineries notamment qui a
rapporté à la russie l'an dernier 24
milliards de dollars qui va être touché
des secteurs aussi en matière de
transport donc c'est toute l'économie
russe et tous ses secteurs stratégiques
qui sont aujourd'hui prod pour cible à
la fois par les européens mais ne
l'oublions pas par nos autres alliés
puisque les américains les canadiens les
le royaume uni ont aussi adopté des
sanctions de même nature extrêmement
sévère et si jamais kiev tombe parce
qu'il est patent est ce qu'il sera pas
temps de prendre la décision d'exclure
la russie de swift écoutez nous n'en
sommes pas là donc à ce stade nous
poursuivrons nos discussions mais comme
je l'indiquais de notre côté nous sommes
favorables à cette mesure merci beaucoup
anne claire le journe d'avoir été avec
nous et merci d'être venus sur france 24